hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be examining whether there is any way
for the rest of the world to defeat Eren
in his new massive Titan form in
particular I will be looking at whether
the newly formed Alliance which consists
of five different Titan shifters to
Ackerman's and the brilliant strategist
and inventor han Jie could potentially
stop Eren from destroying the entire
world as he has vowed to do clearly I am
i setting up a massive conflict between
this newly formed alliance and Godzilla
Eren but what is this confrontation
going to look like and does anyone
actually stand a chance against Aaron
that is what I'll be talking about in
this video so let's get into it
if you enjoy our attack on Titan videos
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar or you just haven't had a
chance to subscribe please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons who make videos
like this one possible with all the
constant problems facing youtubers
patron support means more than ever so
thank you guys so much I'll talk more
about patreon at the end of the video
but first please be advised that this
video will contain attack on Titan manga
spoilers I am dealing with the very
latest information in the attack on
Titan stories so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in recent
chapters we saw a very unlikely Alliance
take shape in the attack on Titan story
after Aaron went full godzilla mode
initiated the rumbling and vowed to
destroy the entire world except for the
island of parodies the Jaeger asad by
the glorious King Emperor flock seized
full control of the political and
military institutions on the island
everyone who opposes Aaron's plan or the
Jaeger ists in general has been forced
into hiding and this extreme set of
circumstances has given rise to a very
unlikely alliance of some of the
strongest Islanders and Marlins Levi
Mikasa Armin and hanji along with Corney
and Jean decided to form an alliance
with
any Reiner peak McGough Gabi and Falco
this means that five Titan shifters the
colossal Titan the female tightened the
armor tightened the cart tighten and the
jaw tighten are now seemingly on the
same team
and on top of that they also have the
power of two unstoppable Ackerman's Levi
and Mikasa along with the strategic and
scientific brilliance all hanji
depending on how many contacts and
resources McGrath still has in the
Marlon Army this alliance may
potentially gain access to some of
Marley's more advanced technology at
some point in the near future but even
though this alliance would have been
considered incredibly stacked at any
other point in the attack on Titan story
at this point with Aaron attaining a new
gigantic Titan form and initiating the
rumbling even this stacked Alliance is a
massive underdog in any potential fight
against Aaron so can they do anything to
stop Aaron or is he already unstoppable
I made a whole video speculating about
just how strong Aaron might be in his
new Titan form and I will link that
video in the description if you want to
check it out I won't be rehashing all of
his potential powers and abilities here
but it is enough to say that even before
attaining his new form he had access to
the attack Titans powers and a warhammer
Titans powers after Aaron is able to
reach the consciousness or essence of a
mere Fritz the progenitor of all the
Titans he convinces her to stop obeying
the orders of the royal family and to
seek freedom together with him in that
moment Aaron is seemingly able to unlock
the true potential of the founding Titan
despite the fact that he does not have
any royal blood and that is when he
transforms into a completely new Titan
form a form unlike anything that we've
ever seen before by my own rough
calculations just judging by the panels
in which we see Aaron's new Titan next
to the wall Titans Aaron's new Titan
form is at least 550 meters tall to put
that into perspective the colossal Titan
shifter is only 60 meters in height and
the tallest tighten that we've seen up
to this point
rod Reese's Titan was 100
20 meters tall so Aaron's new Titan form
is more than four times larger than the
rod reese titan at least by my
unofficial calculations it goes without
saying that a Titan four times the size
of the rod reese titan will have
physical strength on a level that we've
never seen before due to his immense
size aaron's godzilla titan will likely
be pretty slow but the sheer mass and
raw power of this titan will be
unbelievable on top of his insane
physical strength we have been led to
believe that aaron is now able to
control the millions of wall titans
there may be some doubt about how much
control he has over these titans because
even after transforming into his new
form aaron did not command the mindless
titans to stop attacking the humans on
parodies so the question is did Aaron
fail to stop the Titans from attacking
humans because he can't actually control
them as well as we thought or is it
because his alliance with amir fritz
changed him mentally and he stopped
caring about collateral damage
perhaps he became interested only in the
big picture which is the destruction of
the rest of the world and aside from his
unimaginable physical strength and his
titan control aaron is also able to
communicate telepathically with all LD
ins including the Ackerman's using the
founding titan power along with
telepathic communication defining titan
can also alter the memories of aliens
and apparently it can even change the
physical composition of LD ins
everything from potentially sterilizing
them to making them immune to certain
diseases we also know that the founding
titan can create new titans millions of
them just look at all those wall titans
and who knows maybe the founding titan
once controlled by amir fritz herself
can just choose to turn any random LDN
into a titan without the use of spinal
fluid and this could potentially include
all the LD ends on the continent of
Marlay this is not yet fully confirmed
but we cannot underestimate the
potential power of the founding titan
when it is being wielded by the essence
of amir fritz herself it is quite
possible that he Mears founding titan
possesses powers and abilities that we
don't even know about powers that even
the descendants of
mere who had inherited the founding
titan power in the past had no way of
accessing so having said all of that is
there any possible logical or realistic
way for anyone to defeat Aaron including
the newly formed alliance between the
scouts and the Warriors as I mentioned
in the house strongest Aaron's new Titan
form video short of inventing the nuke
and just mass nuking Aaron and the wall
Titans the world's options for stopping
him are very limited with that said in
Chapter 1 to 7 we received some very
interesting pieces of additional
information that may prove useful in any
potential battle against Aaron we
learned from hanji that the Azuma Beto's
have access to a heavier-than-air
aircraft which looks a lot like a small
pre-world war ii era airplane if I
recall correctly virtually all of the
aircraft technology that we've seen in
attack on Titan so far has been lighter
than air so balloons and Zeppelin's and
so on but apparently heavier-than-air
aircraft do also exist this is good news
for the anti Aaron Alliance because
airplanes are significantly faster than
hot air balloons or Zeppelin's and they
are often able to fly higher
however the airplane also has some
disadvantages over the airship it has a
limited flight range because it runs on
fuel and it is much smaller than an
airship the aircraft can probably only
carry like four people by the looks of
it but this is just my assumption based
on the brief glimpse that we got of the
aircraft in Chapter one to seven
maybe it's bigger than it looks and
maybe can carry like a dozen people tops
but it definitely can't carry an entire
army or anything close to that so
theoretically the newly-formed anti
Aaron alliance could put Levi Micasa and
a couple of Titan shifters on a plane
and fly all the way up to the top of
Aaron's new Titan form they could then
drop down on his head and attempt to
take him down by going for the nape of
his neck the shifters would obviously
have to transform only after landing on
Aaron because they can't transform
inside the plane so let's say then
Mikasa Levi and a couple of Titan
shifters are able to pull this off and
land on top of Aaron what could they do
next well first off the single best
Titan
shifter for this mission would be the
jaw tighten because he is fast and great
at climbing and also his incredibly
strong jaw could be the best thing to
break through the name of Aaron's giant
Titan neck so the jaw Titan would
definitely be able to move and climb
around Aaron's Massa Titan frame and
carry Levi and the others right up to
the nape of Aaron's neck the jaw Titan
could also then help break through the
neck and get Aaron out from the inside
the problem is that the jaw Titan is
currently in the possession of Falco and
Falco has never even transformed into
the jaw Titan before Falco is completely
inexperienced as a Titan shifter and
this makes sending the jaw tighten on
this mission completely impractical at
least for the foreseeable future the
armored Titan would probably be pretty
useless and I don't think that the Kart
Titan would be ideal either the car
titan does have great agility and
endurance but being on four legs the
Kart Titan would have a much harder time
climbing around a moving Titans body
than say the jaw Titan maybe I'm wrong
here because the car Titan has been seen
climbing buildings before but at any
rate the car titans climbing abilities
cannot be compared to the jaw titans the
female Titan is pretty agile and she is
also highly skilled in close range
combat so she might be a good option if
the goal is to get Aaron out of the
Titan without killing him then getting
Levi Meek Assad the female Titan and
possibly the car Titan up there and
trying to break through the Titans
massive nape is their best bet but when
I say massive nape I really mean massive
absolutely gigantic way bigger and
thicker than anything that we've seen
before even Levi's Sonic the Hedgehog
mode may not be capable of slicing
through all that Titan flesh and if they
can't find a way to break through then
the entire mission will fail the Titans
and the Ackerman's on top of Aaron will
be little more than flies to him they
won't be able to stop him even though
this all seems like an almost impossible
mission if their goal is to stop Aaron
without killing him this will be their
best bet and yeah good luck they got a
climb on top and find a way to rip Aaron
out but if they decide that they want to
stop Aaron at all costs
even if this means killing him in the
process then the anti Aaron alliance
does have one other option the final
option would be to use our men's
colossal Titan this Titan is slow and
has no agility but he does have the
ability to generate a massive explosion
that closely resembles a nuclear bomb
if Arman is taken up to Aaron's nape
with the aircraft and if arm and then
detonates his colossal explosion right
next to eren's Titan named the force of
that explosion might be enough to
destroy the nape and Aaron with it this
would likely kill both Aaron and Armin
but Aaron would be stopped
although to be fair this is assuming
that Aaron's new Titan form isn't too
strong even for this explosion if it is
strong enough to withstand the explosion
then there is no hope there is no way to
Levi Myka saw or anyone else will be
able to break through and speaking of
Mikasa which plan the anti Eren alliance
decides to execute may largely depend on
her in Chapter one to seven Mikasa
confirmed that she wants to stop Eren
because she feels that destroying the
entire world is wrong but she also says
that she wants to stop Eren without
killing him this means that Mikasa would
certainly oppose the Armin nuclear
explosion strategy and if they decide to
go with that plan the Alliance might
have to fight off Mikasa first before
they ever get to Aaron to make things
worse in Chapter 1 to 7 we learned at
the port that the Alliance was planning
to use to get to Aaron has been occupied
by the Jaeger ists and Kiyomi has been
taken into custody and is currently
being held at gunpoint by flock and his
jägermeister x' I feel like flock and
the jägermeister x' might be a pretty
good band name anyway this means that
even getting their hands on an aircraft
and getting to Aaron in the first place
may prove to be unimpacted apart where
they have to actually stop Aaron's
gigantic Titan form so can the world
including the newly formed alliance
between the Scouts and Marlin warriors
really stop Aaron well it's not out of
the realm of possibility the options are
extremely limited since I don't think
that the Marlins have secretly invented
nuclear weapons and since I don't think
that just having a friend
chat with Aaron will stop him at this
point the only plausible way to defeat
Aaron is to somehow reach his nape using
humans airplane and then either cut
Aaron out or blow him up
along with his gigantic Titan for either
of these two scenarios to be effective a
lot of things will have to come together
perfectly including recovering Kiyomi
and taking her airplane making it all
the way up to Aaron before the fuel runs
out
selecting the right people to go on the
mission itself and executing the mission
once they actually reach Aaron is it
impossible no this is manga and in the
world of manga anything is possible but
it will definitely be extremely
interesting to watch whether any of
these scenarios will actually play out
let me know what you guys think do you
believe that the newly formed Alliance
will somehow succeed in stopping Aaron
and if so how is Aaron really going to
destroy the entire world or does he
actually have some other plan in mind
but he just wants everyone to think that
this is what he's doing please give me
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't go through the trouble of hitting
the bell and selecting the option that
says all you're gonna miss a ton of our
videos it's just how YouTube works I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime out pro patrons for supporting
our work and making these videos
possible with all the constant problems
on YouTube patron support is more
important than ever thank you guys so
much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata Alan Adam the world Steelers the
school bus Tyson Kadena acquired respect
and Pat a heffa and I can't forget our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings Eldred fitted ala
beat alpha do Anatoli Cassatt ski on
hell Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP
Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
Vargas Shawn
dark Joe Stanton JCC Wacha very Gucci
and Jessica Kay lafawn if you enjoy our
videos and you think that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]